ladies and gentlemen we may uh uh have
some we have some breaking news here I'm
seeing this this is just tweeted out by
Jesse Waters take a look Joe Biden to
visit Israel on Wednesday didn't I say
this like 20 minutes ago that he was
that Joe Biden was going there yeah
tomorrow oh okay wow you said it quietly
you didn't announce it in a in a cool
radio host voice Monday he's going there
Wednesday right he's going there
Wednesday wait it's not Tuesday it's not
Tuesday it's impossible say what day it
is um sorry everyone it seems like a
really bad idea for Joe Biden to going
to an active conflict Zone when Rockets
are blowing up over maybe that's the
plan yeah maybe this is your Gavin
Newsome Rises to the occasion moment I
was kind of thinking that yeah and I
mean that this is 911 lose our president
it does seem like it could be kind of a
setup it could be the LI pin you know
well let's think about this how do you
get rid of kamla Harris everyone says if
Joe Biden bows out kamla's next in line
she has to run is she going with him
there what I'm not saying that I'm
saying what if Joe Biden you know God
forbid something bad happens when he's
over in Israel which is the cast's belly
for us intervention in the region kamla
Harris assumes the role Office of the
presidency and then steps down at the
end of the term and it and and it goes
to a new candidate oh I see there one
way that feasibly kamla Harris drops out
is that she actually serves and then
says I I did my duty and now I'm going
to be stepping down I think she would
drop out I think that she would be
unburdened by What Might Have Been I was
going to say stick it out I think it
we're talking about the C a very intense
internal battle because I think she
would not want to give up the shot at
being first I completely disagree I
don't think she would win she wouldn't
want to go she's a muppet she's just
like clearly the lady can't talk have
you ever heard her a spe she say the
same thing over and over and over again
she really doesn't want to be there no
she she laughs and says nonsense she got
her and so if if the plan from our
intelligence apparatus was to get in a
new a new candidate who is going to
actually be able to inspire to some
degree it ain't kamla and Kam's not
going to do it because they're gonna
tell her no Joe Biden is here now and
it's not so much about Joe Biden not
being a part of the deep state or or the
bureaucratic State or the administrative
State it's that you need a clean PR exit
if Joe Biden goes I'm too old I got to
go everyone's going to say okay what
about Kamala we also know she can't win
right if something bad happens to Biden
deep state gets its War it's cass's
belly Kamala Harris then assumes the
role for the next year and or year and a
half and then says I did my duty I'm now
going to hand it off to those who are
more capable y y y and honorably hands
the the passes the torch down to
somebody else and she she served as vice
president first female whatever she
wants to identify as vice president
sometimes it's Asian sometimes it's
black first female president y first one
Fe yep and she also got to serve for
like one day as president because Joe
Biden had to go under anesthesia for
like a colon right so so she already was
the first president that was female so
so it's all out of the way it's gotten
out of the way so she doesn't have to
serve now because she's already been one
but assuming the role for a short period
would be like legitimately hitting that
hit that marker I think it's the ideal
case for her and I think it just depends
on how entrenched she is in uh obeying
her commanders right I I think if she's
but the thing about Biden is that I
think he does not want to go he will put
up a fight he wants to retain power for
as long as possible maybe Kamala is more
compliant and she would exit after you
know half a term or whatever she has
left to serve I just think all of these
people are so power hungry that once
they get into the chair they don't want
to leave it believe that she can serve
for two full terms after the midpoint so
she for 10 years how many people in this
country would support us intervention
into the Middle East particularly the is
Israel region Israel Jordan Etc how many
people would support that if Joe Biden
was critically wounded by Hamas yep or
Hezbollah or Iran yeah Iran yeah I mean
look I'll I'll I'll say right now I I
imagine all of the neolibs are going to
outright be in favor of it we are all
going to find ourselves sharing talking
points with many leftists who are
anti-war not because they agree with us
but because they will exploit whatever
the the modern the modern narrative is
to gain power and if their support is
for Palestine we will all say something
like foreign intervention is a mistake
it'll cause World War II and they'll
parrot those talking points in an effort
to try and seize power you will then get
someone like Ben Shapiro who will
undoubtedly say they they this is these
are terrorists who have killed Israelis
and now they've targeted our president
and this Administration the US
absolutely must must you're going to get
every conservative like 90% of
conservatives saying the US must
intervene I think there would be huge
support for military intervention if
they went after the president but it
does seem ridiculous that we're putting
the president in directly In Harm's Way
yeah it is ridiculous are exping
and he wouldn't go to what paline Ohio
but he will go here like what is going
on B why he also won't go to the Border
still I don't understand this risk
management why is one thing okay when we
know there is very violent active
conflict but the other places that they
kept saying no it's fine he won't go
this doesn't make sense y also I think
blinkin is in
charge barely yeah but like it seems
like it I think he's the one who's
making all the all of these decisions
and he was just in talk for S hours so I
mean now we need Biden to come in Biden
are a very effective and charismatic
leader he can like fall off the stage in
Jerusalem instead of it's rough I don't
like this it just we look
so I'm worri about Rockets exploding the
Iron Dome failing it's almost like he's
intentionally being set up yes how could
you not feel that way that's what it
looked like to me earlier today and I
was like no that's crazy don't think
that remember when Obama said to Joe you
don't have to do this he was really
saying is Joe don't don't sacrifice
yourself for this country going back to
how many people would be in favor of of
uh something if the if it happened to
the president I mean I think Congress
had something like a 90% approval rating
when it came to 911 and everybody was
just so in favor of War so in favor of
the Patriot Act so in favor of justice
and Redemption and and so I think that
it wouldn't be that high but I think
it'd be probably like 70% you know if we
can kind of think about how what
percentage of conservatives would be
behind it what percentage Neo lives be
behind it we could probably get a pretty
rough estimate about it's a legitimately
difficult question M would would any any
of us here any of you watching let's
let's not let's not enter like let's say
Joe Biden on good on good faith let's
say on good faith is trying to actually
deescalate and he's going there to tell
them Joe Biden's already publicly stated
he they should not invade Gaza so okay
let's say on good faith Joe Biden really
is trying to
deescalate if
Hamas attacks and and in any way removes
Joe Biden I'll be very light on my
language would you listening comment
below let me you think support us
intervention to go after those who
committed the act that that you know
targeted our
president I one could really use another
fool around and find out tweet from
Donald
Trump what if Donald Trump then says as
much as we think Joe Biden look we think
he's crooked but and then he decides we
are going after the terrorists has he
what has he has how has he been on
Israel or even Ukraine for that he just
put out a statement saying he will not
allow the refugees or the these people
coming he still seems America First he's
very America first but he's also he's
also said that he stands with BB and he
said I stand with BB and I stand with
Israel so you know I do think that he
does Israel is a long-standing Ally and
um you know I'm I'm fully in support of
Israel's right to defend themselves I
will say M if if if our president were
assassinated by a a foreign agent on
foreign soil I would recommend literally
destroying whatever nation was behind
it's the most impossible situation
because you want to be at least I would
like to be as anti- interventionalist
America First is that's not
anti-interventionist that's retaliatory
it's retaliatory at that point and
that's that's the difference I'm good if
we can just keep the kids out of it yeah
true but everyone in the chat is saying
no way no no way no us retaliation if we
have no retaliation to presidential
assassination by a foreign agent then we
have no Nation because we're we're
involved in a very different way than we
are right now if our president were
assassinated on foreign soil by the CIA
and uh this is kind of what we're where
we're at now I it's like us has
discovered oil in the US will be
deploying a military force to liberate
the us from the
US yeah it's a good one yeah that checks
out I mean there are there are you know
organizations in the world that really
hate the United States and want to see
us destroyed fully one of those is Hamas
like I mean I wonder if people would be
saying if Donald like here's another
question if Joe Biden was sitting in the
White House and the White House got
attacked and foreign agents you know
took the life of Joe Biden in the white
house should there be a a retaliation
fly article four section four that's
what our military is there for very
fully defense of our nation what about
Ron Paul had the view that we should
issue letters of Mark Mark and reprisal
those to Target specifically the actors
who did it and not declare war on entire
nations right so when it came to 911 his
argument was Al-Qaeda did this it's not
Iraq it's not Afghanistan we should have
issued letters of Mark and reprisal and
gone after Al-Qaeda specifically so so
if anybody doesn't really know what
letters of Mark are it's it's in the
Constitution it's like something article
something Section 8 Clause 11 um it's
it's essentially that they can make
Americans mercenaries or make Americans
honorary Pirates essentially the
honorary pirate Clause okay so so if we
get in a seaw war or a land war with
Russia or China or Iran or whatever um
the Congress can write these letters of
Mark and say oh you own a boat you get
to be a pirate now and then you get to
go be a pirate yeah yeah that's why
after 911 theyed a fireboat and there's
actually more to this Clause too or how
they've interpreted it like you get to
take their booty and and but you have to
split the booty with Congress that was
kind of the original reading of the
letters of Mark Nancy Pelosi's got to
get hers get a boat this is what people
don't realize Pirates were were
basically under Crown protection during
Like Pirates of the Caribbean you Barber
Pirates I mean but it it just there were
so many more right the the Britain
basically says hey go go disrupt French
supply lines and we'll protect you and
then when France is like you're
attacking our ships like oh those are
pirates never I think John Adams
actually uh it was John Adam y against
the barber the barbery Pirates yeah he
was really he was working on
negotiations with them yeah it was a
whole big thing MH to just try and get
their ships to to get across yeah so
they could trade well after the uh war
for independence the uh uh Britain was
still
kidnapping capturing US citizens and
forcing them to serve on their ships
crazy impr anyway in the in in the
effect uh in the instance that something
does happen to Joe Biden so here's a
question if so if Joe Biden goes
overseas and something happens to him
people have mostly said no no we should
not intervene because of that what if
it's Donald Trump what if Donald Trump
went to North Korea to negotiate peace
crossed the DMZ and then once he got up
you know 50 feet in they bashed him over
the head and dragged his body off to a
prison should the us then go to war with
North Korea even if it means CH and then
China says I don't think we should go to
war with North Korea I think we should
destroy North Korea and then China says
if you make any moves on North Korea we
will nuke New York I would still say
then we nuke them too that's World War
II well we're anyway if they destroy our
if they kill our president we're already
there yeah I was going to say the
president thing is is a level of
Engagement from the other side that we
are not currently at can we encourage
them bomb Hollywood on top of New York
City I mean can we can we can we like
what about the children yeah we get the
children out bomb the movie star
Remember The Simpsons hallowen special
with Kang and kotto and they're like
we'll take all we'll we'll take all of
your members of Congress and then Homer
Homer Mar like you couldn't get all of
them could you ah just watch us and
they're like all right can we help like
oh no don't yeah I was going to say I
wonder what the simp have predicted
about this well a lot of a lot of people
are saying if if Donald Trump was was
attacked or targeted yes we should
intervene so it's it's more of a
political question than than anything
else but I think that's the problem like
as much as I don't like Biden he is
still the president so if another
country you know attacked him on foreign
soil it is still a serious crime against
America it hasn't happened I don't know
why we are sending Biden there stupid it
is just very stupid do make any sense
this is my concern I mean there's look
man you can be as anti- intervention as
you want but you're going to you're
going to convince there there's a lot of
people are going to be like yeah killing
a president is is grounds for Invasion
yes I fully think if like if anything
anything is ground for reprisal it is
quite literally killing our president
yes I fully agree with that that's
terrifying Biden should not be going to
a conflict Zone like this right now very
stupid makes no sense it's Ohio was too
dangerous right no it wasn't dangerous I
just didn't want to go it doesn't any
sense be fair the border is probably too
dangerous yeah true well apparently it's
not as dangerous as this situation so I
don't really know what they're
communicating to us I I I think this is
the weird thing about the theatrics of
the Biden Administration is that nothing
is logical nothing makes sense and so
you have to sort of suspend trying to
make it reasonable uh and that's why we
can have these conversations that are
like are they setting him up because it
seems like they might be because logic
really bizarre to send your president to
an active war zone like this where
you're deploying your Marines right but
everything where and where there's like
active terrorists seeking to destroy the
nation that he is going to visit is he
got to be guarded by all those Marines
and are they going to like send the
Marines over with Biden and then just
leave the Marines there is that
essentially what's happening maybe yeah
well the Marines are already in the area
aren't they already like not in the US
they're nearby here are reporting got a
lot of guys in Germany right they were
in Kuwait yeah many of them were in
Kuwait I don't know where these other
guys are coming from but uh yeah we're
sending 200,000 troops and the
president's heading there you know this
doesn't bode well did he did he go to
Maui in the end or did he not end go
Maui I'm going to go hang out in the
store room with all my food buckets and
just you know turn the lights off went
to Maui because that's a good question
too I mean that was the other one Biden
he did go to Maui Yeah Tim did he was on
vacation
in Utah maybe uh what's the lake there
uh Tahoe Tahoe he was on vacation in
Tahoe and he took a morning and an
afternoon maybe I think and went to Maui
oh wow nice him he he and a little and
Biden didn't go to New York on 911 he
went to Alaska but to be fair New York
is is too dangerous for the president he
didn't go to 911 but he said he went to
n he went to New York on
911 in 2001 even though he didn't he
went with a little Congressional de
delegation a few days after because he
was literally in Congress giving a
speech and there's video of it I mean to
be fair you know a lot of it is that
he's just a liar and he's always been
but he also does have like and I mean
it's quite literally like serious brain
damage from like aneurysms and surgery
so it's it's not funny I mean it's true
leader of our country that we are now
being like hey everyone's on the brink
of tension so let's send Joe Biden in to
put things what I hate his little old
man walk when he walks around he's the
dementia Shuffle is sad but it's like
it's not what I would like and a
president that is that is probably the
better point that of all the people we
need to be sending to Israel to like
talk down the war we're sending the
worst it doesn't make sense it's like we
want to get things to get worse maybe we
should CIA is like go I think that
they're doing it in the same way because
so many people are invested in in in
this this war and it's almost like it's
it's almost like when George W bush went
to 9 to 911 and put his armor on the
firefighter and I think they they think
they're going to get something like that
they are not yes exactly did did Biden
ever go to Ukraine I know the first lady
went to Ukraine at one point KLA Harris
went too KLA Harris went did but did Joe
Biden go to Ukraine I don't remember
Boris Johnson went yeah he did he did go
to Ukraine I I think Biden oh Biden went
and there were like fake Air Sirens they
they like set off air raid sirens and no
one looked at all perturbed because they
were or something he went this year like
a year into the conflict he went yeah he
went after but and he went he waited
some good time for this thing that we
spent billions of dollars which is
different than if Biden was kidna
napped and and smuggled into tan and
they put him on camera and they had him
and they were like we have your
President should the US invade Iran we
don't negotiate with terrorists also
immedi sorry Jo immediately defund the
Secret Service who clearly did a
terrible job or was complicit all right
yep yeah if he gets kidnapped I'm sorry
but that just a waste of money I'm just
asking this hypothetical in in in like
would people support a US invasion of
Iran if they kidnap our president the
chat saying about the chat uh uh
everyone's saying give kamla a pay
raise no no no how dare you I think
obviously to do what we could to protect
our president Trump would not want us to
negotiate with terrorists that's some of
his ads is that Joe Biden negotiates
with terrorists and look what happened
and he's like I don't negotiate with
terrorist imagine would go get him but
also they have Trump in like a chair and
he's tied up Trump they put a camera on
and they're like if you don't give us
you know $5 billion we you know if you
give if you want your president release
and then Trump rips The Mask up he's
like don't do it don't give him anything
and they hit him and then he's like no
and then you know like a movie no he'
probably just get elected in their
country you know like he's so
charismatic they' be like it's making
some great points this New Yorker like
can you are pres everyone's saying yes
to Trump if it's Trump we go in bid no
isue is that B it's not about Biden or
Trump it's about the representative of
our nation yeah that's ultimate what
comes down to I understand it's on us
that we have a
super just an awful awful
represent leader of our nation that's
humiliating it is yeah it's that we
don't have an inspirational president
who we want to go save I don't even want
an inspirational president I just want
someone who can think thoughts all the
way through from beginning to end that's
too high good decisions and project
confidence and a little bit of insanity
at the rest of the world I remember
something they used someone who falls
upstairs I remember something that they
used to do with Trump when he would go
and meet with foreign leaders and they'd
be like like look at you know these
people don't respect him at all and they
be like like Justin trau like like you
know all femininely looking him up and
down you want Justin Trudeau to respect
you though exactly right this is the
thing and every be like yeah see the the
foreign world doesn't respect Donald
Trump it's like really like like can can
we do can we can we talk about Joe Biden
now can we talk about the respect also
no one respects Joe Biden at all not at
all no they're like not even his wife
who let him run for president no no God
no yeah they don't respect him at all
they I mean The Border's wide open like
every body lit their prisoners out to
come to our country the minute he got in
office I mean you can track it right
down to January 20th or whatever the to
the El Salvador president who put all
those guys in prison so that they're not
crossing the B that dude's that dude's
hting out of the ballpark man yeah
definitely El Salvador's killing it yeah
I mean literally Trump like not Trump
but Biden's been disrespected to his
face like he landed in China that time
and they just didn't meet him there as
they didn't have the delegation there
and he said there oh well I guess like
they'll figure it out did the same thing
to Trump trump just turned on left
immediately cuz you realiz that they're
it's a big disc bro it's not really cool
yeah so yeah they don't for someone who
got criticized for not being
presidential he would not have taken
diplomatic SN exactly man I'm really
worried about Wednesday yeah there
there's there's so I mean with the
investigations into the bidens if
something bad happens to him there's no
political circumstance in which people
are going to be all of it gone I all the
under Biden stuff gone all the Joe Biden
bisma Ukraine all of it gone anything
bad happens to him m it's dude they were
like sacrificing their Queen in ch chess
you know what I'm saying this is what it
feels like oh it is it's the queen
sacrifice interesting if you if you
think he's like a person that can move
anywhere on the board and do all these
things I don't think he move himself I
think someone else makes the decision
which is how it works with chess cuz he
needs somebody else's hand he is yeah
he's perceived as the most powerful
person in the United States like the
queen you know protects the king but is
the king the Deep state who's the king
we don't have a king yeah the Deep State
yeah yeah and they say it's time for you
to go by to to serve your country this
is what you need to and that's the thing
because he'll kind of go down if
something God forbid happens like nobody
wants that to happen nobody wants so
nobody would wish that but if something
God forbid you know happen but it gives
the Deep State literally
everything nothing bad could like come
of that and this move him going to
Israel this doesn't track like I said no
border he didn't go to Ohio he won't
even go to New York but he he he went to
Ukraine after a year of conflict but he
puts a LD on and he's like I'm going to
Israel immediately it doesn't make sense
that was the Monday after this war
started he put a lid on it by like 11:54
a.m. but they were still kind of putting
out statements right they were sort of
vaguely I mean you had kjp there on
Twitter doesn't make any sense she's the
worst yeah she is but they'll stick by
her that's I was kind of expecting her
to not make She's a Lesbian so they have
to stick by her because she is a
diversity hire because of her sexual
orientation and they they put gender
identity
who you like to sleep with as the most
important qualifiers for how you get a
job in the Biden administ did you ever
think you'd Miss Jen that was my
question uh no but I kind of do
sometimes I I don't watch her show
though no I don't watch I don't miss it
that much this I this just to add on to
this briefly before we jump on the next
story it is so weird the obsession with
sex the left has where it's like exactly
what you're saying you have these these
hires where it's like okay and the job
is train operator and who do you sleep
with yeah it's like uh and so I'll just
add to this cuz uh you guys know I've
been playing balers gate modern video
game AAA game comes out every character
is trying to trying to have sex with
with your characters like you have four
different characters you have a party
and you you play as each one of them
each have their own story line but it's
basically the whole game makes literally
no sense because of it and it's really
annoying and people have been
complaining about it but what happens is
with this wokeness they're like anybody
can have a relationship with anybody mhm
but but it's just like the problem is
when I'm going like on a on a on a job
right like we go to Miami we're going to
go to Miami and we're going to go down
and put on a show the idea that everyone
will be constantly trying to just like
the only conversations you're having
about how you trust and love and want to
have sex with each other is just like
the weirdest thing imaginable also that
seems really icky and kind of like it
makes everything awkward Yes Men
everyone in the game is racist in the
game like that's like explicit like
people in the game are racist so it's
it's like just sex and racism huh I I
don't mean to bring up just this one
game my point is
left popular culture when it comes to
the workplace professional when it comes
to entertainment is the most important
thing is who you're banging yeah that's
weirdest thing I always thought it was
weird I have friends who work for some
big you know Corporate America type
companies and they will be like oh yeah
I got you know I I've come out and so
therefore I got put on our lgbtq
whatever panel and I help organize
trainings at work and there's sort of
this weird industry that all hinges on
the fact that you have disclosed who
you're sleeping with or what your sexual
habits are why would you want that
especially in some sort of structure
corporate like this must be an HR
nightmare somewhere down the line thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net